roulement de tambour
malgré leur déception par rapport à
certaines décisions comme la promesse
brisée du troisième lien les militants
kakistes ne doute pas de leur chef
[Musique]
avec
98,6%, il a les coups de France
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur et pour le pays des fois il
y a des éditions difficiles à faire pour
les enfants mais c'est la même chose ici
à grande échelle on doit faire des choix
mais l'important c'est d'avoir ça
ensemble je suis pas parce que j'avais
pleinement confiance que tout le monde
allait se rallier à notre premier
ministre une dose d'énergie dont il
avait besoin c'est pas facile le
gouverner et c'est des arbitrages c'est
jamais tout blanc ou tout noir
maintenant François Legault sent qu'il
peut se tourner vers l'avenir on doit
lancer un grand chantier d'efficacité
énergétique pour pallier un besoin
grandissant en électricité tout le monde
devra faire son effort afin de réduire
sa consommation le projet de loi déposer
l'automne prochain et touchera les
entreprises comme les clients
résidentiels
je pense que on peut moduler tarif moi
je pense qu'on peut convaincre les gens
à changer leurs habitudes l'autre
chantier freiner le déclin du français
pour ça le Premier ministre répète qu'il
faut miser sur l'immigration francophone
contrôler par Québec il faut commencer
par utiliser les pouvoirs qu'on a à
Québec mais faut aussi dans un deuxième
temps aller chercher les boîtes à ta
voix un début de Man
dat magique maintenant derrière lui et
qu'il pourra se concentrer sur son
programme politique comme lui ont
demandé si militants en fin de semaine
ici Véronique Reims Radio-Canada à
sherbro